having just one drink a day could impact
your brain that's according to a new
large scale study I usually have
probably one drink a new study finds
even just a few beers or glasses of wine
a week may also be risky I was surprised
at just how little alcohol seems to be
necessary to reduce brain volume
researchers from the University of
Pennsylvania looked at data on more than
36,000 adults and found light to
moderate drinking was associated with
reductions in overall brain volume
increasing drinking from about half a
Beer a Day to a pint of beer led to
changes in the brain equivalent to aging
2 years this is new research with brand
new technology saying that one drink
shrinks your brain Jesus says I come to
give you life more abundantly and Daniel
said he wouldn't defile his body with
the King's Wine God said whoever defiles
his Temple which is you he will destroy
let's stop defending this brain
shrinking Soul defiling toxic chemical
the truth will set you free